huh they all said I feel good show
though the second last question and i
heard i hope that this when you read
this because you actually have the full
solution to that original question in
your water when you read it i hope it
will make sense ok so here it goes last
question hold on to your hats if you've
got a triangle ABC and i'm going to put
another PQ in here ok another PQ but i'm
going to put a PQ in such that this area
here and this area here are the same ok
this is what I want if P is somewhere
over here where will QB such that P Q by
sex this area that's the question I'm
trying to answer okay it's a very bad
diagram and I hardly know where to start
so therefore can you draw for me three
little copies of this diagram and I'll
show you what we're going to do kind of
like a moving diver
okay so what I want you to imagine this
is an incredibly powerful idea in
mathematics which we call up we kind of
call the Bacchus where a point can move
about according to certain rules like my
question is where is Q and that's where
my questions so to work out where it is
I want to imagine we're here will be as
P changes I want to work out as it moves
along this line what it's going to do so
at the moment he is like out in the
middle of nowhere I have no idea what
it's doing so I'm going to imagine this
imagine that p is actually sitting on
top of where a is at the moment okay I
want you to imagine that's where it
starts okay if that's where P is on the
base of the puppies we've looked at this
morning you should be able to me where q
is PQ is going to bisect his triangle
right by city area so if P starts right
up there where will you be come on
figure out the last two questions we
just did we're just going to go yeah we
do if I pull it q there at the midpoint
of B and C it will work why will it work
why would work if I've divine it up okay
very good you can imagine like a
parallel line up here and look these two
trailers are going to share the same
perpendicular height which we've been
looking at but the ratio of their basis
is one to one so their areas will be one
to one so they're equal very good okay
now what happens is what happens if P
starts to move away starts to move
towards see right well if P sort of ends
up over here cuz it's move that way
right q is also going to move which way
will it move it's gotta move to the left
clearly asked to move to the left right
why is that why does it have to move
like uh this way and not the other way
why won't it be half you're exactly
right why won't it be half anymore if
for instance if P moved but you stay put
why wouldn't it be a half at him they'll
have different heights very good see how
p is dropping down right it's getting
shorter and shorter and shorter not to
mention the fact that this guy over here
not even gonna be trying anymore it's
going to be ours I don't know if it's
just a quarter a four-sided thing ok so
what is going to do is it can't stay put
it certainly can't move to the right
either because it will make this
triangle even smaller right does that
make sense so moves to the left kind of
to compensate does that make sense now
here's my question how far can pay move
how far can pin you can p move to see
career all the way it's actually can't
canon what will happen is pain will get
to in this spot here right which is the
middle of those two of that of that link
and it will stop why there wait yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think that's very so
cute Q's gonna go over here right that's
like she's going to stop why does it
stop there for the same reason that Q
was over here right because I oh I'm
just now got a different orientation
does that make sense and now again I've
sort of got these two bisecting okay so
therefore where does Q have to be on
this diagram in here answer it's
somewhere somewhere between B and the
midpoint of BC does that make sense so
keep draw that info neutral mentally
let's point in daddy's on our original
be diagram right if d is the midpoint of
vc kids gotta be somewhere on this
interval okay so what I'm hoping is I
can make a comparison between this and
the whole area now remember back to this
diagram right I actually have a triangle
related to D that is exactly half
the area namely this guy you see that
this is the one you talked about before
see here as if a BP rather we're up here
on a york yacht in the middle so do you
agree that ABC ABC is half of the whole
triangle do you agree with that so what
I want is for peak usage weapons to be
exactly equal to ABC because then it'll
be half the area and then we'll buy set
so i want i want pqc to be equal to this
half area triangle how do I do that does
it look familiar
aha so if i put in some extra lines here
right like say this guy right have a
look at this triangle and see how it
relates to this one that one in fact is
this one on its side right it's kind of
its kind of falling over good up right
so what's it got this is this leg here
corresponds to PQ on our all right in
fact into one look here's a common area
I want this ADC right and this pqc to be
the same how do I do that what condition
do we have over there and the answer is
if I have a parallel pair of light T
this is that trapezium that you saw
before right do you notice it okay so if
you've got these things and I'm pretty
much done now right in between here
you've got a pair of triangles let's put
them in now and they have to be the same
here we go this guy here has to be the
same as this guy here why what's the
reason train goes between parallel lines
and they share the same base same base
right there okay therefore since these
two are equal therefore the big
triangles that they're inside namely ABC
the sky and PQ see the sky must also be
the same because what you do is add what
do we call it this is P let's add p cd2
both sides just like we did over there
right this is the top triangle a d see
you see that but that's what these two
triangles started with right over here
on the Left PCD m vcd + PQ c is this one
p q sea and the right-hand triangle is
this one right so to finish right then
if you've got any triangle you like
right if I started back here right and
you put P any way you want over here
like saying that's poppin okay to find
out how to slice this thing in half how
do you slice it okay all you need to do
is work out okay well I want these two
legs to be parallel to each other right
these two Leyte so if you draw like say
where am I going to draw something like
this
like that if these two are parallel like
so then all you need to do is slice
across that's how i did it over here
that's where that's what gave me q okay
once you've got that this area must be
exactly half of the whole thing okay now
did you see how I've stopped that's did
you see how all the way through whenever
I looked at question I said hey wait
wait this connects to this one this one
connects to like the other three I drew
before the question we started with this
morning takes all four of the properties
they just established and that's where
all those numbers come from okay